I think I think that I'm interested in
monsters not because they have a
specific value you know I actually think
they are they have multiple values
depending on how you use them they are
symbols of great power I think that at
some point when we became thinking
creatures we decided to interpret the
world by creating a mythology of gods
and monsters
you know we created angels we created
demons we created serpents devouring the
moon we created a mythology to to make
sense of the world around us and
monsters were born at the same time than
angels or any of the beatific creatures
and characters were created so I don't
assign them a specific value but I do
I am very mindful of the way I deal with
them in the movies and in the books
because I assigned them a specific
function and I tried to take them to the
extreme with that you know I make them
victims or I make them sympathetic or I
make them brutal parasites and they
become a metaphor for something else
obviously monsters are living breathing
metaphors that for me half of the fun is
explaining them so socially biologically
mythologically and so forth
I think the moment we made our
interpretation of the world as a sort of
binary you know type of interpretation
night and day became separate entities
light and dark and we went through the
process of creating the world by an
understanding of the world through
opposites we needed to mythologize and I
think what it tells you is that you know
we is mostly Western with Western
culture thinking there's a Eastern
philosophies that accept the good and
the bad quote unquote as parts of the
whole and that thing that the good flows
with the bad and the bad flows right
back into the good and that that is a
beautiful way of understanding the world
in the universe but Western culture it
tells you that you know the that we
understand the world through opposites
only there's a great phrase a and I'm
gonna miss quoted in the towel saying
essentially that whenever we consider
something good at the same time we are
dealing something bad when we consider
something light is because we're
considering something dark and it's
better to just understand everything as
the everything and abandoned ourselves
to it and so forth but but I I think
that's what it tells you